a michigan nonprofit is taking an
unusual approach to help people who are
formally behind bars by offering them a
chance to learn about farming the group
and its farm is run by someone who knows
firsthand how difficult it can be to
break the cycle of incarceration for our
series a more perfect union on what
unites americans nancy chen shows us how
he is planting seeds of change
i love the sauteed it
it's harvest season once again for
melvin parson
but here on his half acre farm in
ypsilanti michigan
parson isn't just growing kale and
tomatoes he's also growing
opportunity
these are parsons interns taking pride
in the fruits of their labor did i put
stuff over here
not just because of the seats planted
here
but in their own lives they're among a
handful of formerly incarcerated people
working on the we the people opportunity
farm and non-profit parson founded in
2018. did you know anything about
farming before you started this no
i couldn't i couldn't even spell
vegetables
the farm partners with county agencies
like the washington county sheriff's
office to hire people returning from
incarceration for nine months
we're going a lot of
kale parsons mission to break the cycle
of incarceration by providing structure
a steady paycheck and a community often
missing for those re-entering society
i've spent 13 years of my life
incarcerated and i've been homeless
three times and battle substance abuse
and i felt what having my hands in the
soil did to me internally maybe just
maybe
i can offer up something like this
to folks coming home
as many as 27 percent of formerly
incarcerated americans are out of work
according to the prison policy
initiative it's why interns here are
also coached on career building and
financial literacy
this year parson brought on four
participants pony bush has been in and
out of prison for 30 years what's been
the most surprising part about all of
this probably one seed make a lot of
a lot of stuff grow
want to see make a big plan
the vegetables all grown organically and
with the help of experienced farmhands
are sold to some of the area's most
popular restaurants
these two boxes are yours
a portion is also donated to the
community
parson estimates this year's crop
totaled 14 000 pounds and he wants to
keep growing one of your mission
statements is to change the soil yeah of
the people that are here what does that
mean you can be
a farmer that doesn't know what they're
doing like i was and still am in a lot
of ways
but if your soil is good chances are
your plants will flourish and it dawned
on me that the same thing applies to
human beings
incarcerated when she was 17 lawanda
hollister was released after serving 34
years in prison now 52 the world has
changed we came home in may of 2020 what
was that like pandemic was still going
on
i was simply grateful to be home
and for the second chance but where do i
go from there
today hollister is harvesting kale
on other days you'll find her at eastern
michigan university she hopes to start
her own food truck business one day
there's a lot of life lessons in farming
it's about taking care of a plant it's
about watering it's about nurturing it
it's about pruning it when you look at
all of this what do you see i see magic
i see hope i see
the audacity to dream i see the future
for cbs mornings i'm ninci chen in
ypsilanti michigan
it's so important to see that future